this is too close hey guys welcome to a
vlog been a while this is weird
Myanmar's they're taking a weekend going
to Spain and I know how it sounds like
oh yeah
know it I don't think I've ever taken a
summer holiday so we're taking the
weekend okay
I I get it oh they're going it they're
going to Spain for a weekend yeah that's
right we are and you're coming with that
that's right your eyes are not deceiving
you sandals and socks what are you going
to do about it send me to jail can't do
nothing boy
I'm comfy as [ __ ] boy don't do it
[Music]
we're finally here and we are right by
the beach it's super hot is super nice
we're going to change right away and
just go down whoo it's a lot harder than
Brighton that's for sure
very nice I don't know what my site is
doing I like your red bikini like
Baywatch oh you got the underwater
camera it's so shallow back it's
literally sick oh whoa Ethan careful
camera not waterproof I feel like
everyone is looking at me Marinette oh
yeah boy yeah you did name it Batman
oh yeah boy
i legit think i sunburn to select an
hour that's how you know you're sweaty
Sh also we haven't done a room tour
these are safe where we keep all our
important stuff very nice this is our
phone we can make calls with very nice
this is a chair we can sit rather fast
sunset is happening right now let's have
a look at this beautiful view that is
actually gorgeous look at that boy
that's the money shot
I think about something will be so now
we're we're at the beach again TV like
not a whamon what are we doing now
Marsha are you doing today I don't know
why I keep doing these how do you be
minimally yeah it's so attractive there
was something bad in my lunch
I still feel my lunch no one cares
everyone cares about - they stressed
more you're right so beautiful isn't she
the most beautiful woman in the world
have enough you need help you need a
hand girl I do it we just had dinner it
was feminine and now we're going to
watch the season finale
oh what's he called out of it my
customers revenge
masamune Koons revenge yep nay
oh there you are
what are you doing we have to God it's a
new day same blog we're going to this
city center of Majorca my luck whatever
we are so bright here she's crazy
my Norka and then we're heading back
just a chill again
I like those people standing out there
whatever we do Barrett I don't know I
guess we just keep standing here I guess
we do
all right now we're getting all wet
happening it's different windy and I am
finishing as insisted a like the windows
I pay five years
that's pretty to be family got my man
j-dog over here Jesus Christ seem
familiar this is what it's like being
around Marcia I'm just walking down this
hallway just chilling relaxing lexan I
want to remind say what could she have
done I see you okay whoa it's cold damn
my favorite 2014 Brazil you're ready to
lose Martha okay here we go
Jase that's right gentlemen hit me
I want one kicks butt so Wendy I'll
blame the win
yeah you should throw yourself I think
that's as good as to get it's way too
hot to be a suite hear me what how mine
you see the sand it's a windy I see the
sent flying I see it I'm so sunburned I
feel it I feel it Marsh we're going to
rain a boat it looks
if it goes in the water what is it
independent one I have 5% life battery
then I died we are on one of the buses
I'm the captain Gary so it has a thing
on top of it I'm 100% gonna go I'm about
to go on the slide
can we please Karen main the the first I
got to moisturize it
maximum moisture cool
I don't know sir I will oh [ __ ]
how deep do you think the woman right
sorry how do I get up on this baby
[Music]
all right time to see how sunburned I
got Oh what happened here what happened
here what is this why do I look like
Rick my hair is perfect I don't think I
ever looked this good Jeff Hey look a
year let's go have dinner boy
[Music]
we just had some dinner and now did I
get something now you did to my other
math there whoa hey chunk
what is happening whoa whoa whoa whoa
what what the hell oh my god for lobster
I'm so terrible I never eat lobster
again hey wow it does look actually even
on camera it looks like we have fought
back to their talent what is happening
okay all right guys that was our weekend
in my market not cash whatever we are
thank you for coming along so long
farewell auf wiedersehen goodbye boy she
never watched Sound of Music is
disgusting